à gauche depuis qu'il a quitté le parti
socialiste jean luc mélenchon fait
équipe avec la communiste marie george
buffet pour le moment le front de gauche
vous l'avez vu dans notre sondage france
télévisions est crédité de 7% des
intentions de vote ce qui n'empêche pas
le tandem de rêver au pouvoir françoise
david et daniel lévy elles les ont
suivis en campagne
c'est le couple politique du moment
ensemble il avait appelé à voter non à
la constitution européenne en 2005
ensemble marie george buffet jean luc
mélenchon bat la campagne sous la
bannière du front de gauche
partout ils privilégient des rencontres
avec des salariés en colère comme ici
avec ses employés de la ligne b du rer
qui dénonce la politique de bruxelles ça
va être les acquis sociaux qui va être
mise en quoi ça va être le statut
d'entreprise le statut des salariés et
en même temps c'est les usagers qui vont
payer moins cher et marie george buffet
de reprendre à son compte cette
contestation qu'on s'en viennent ici
présents avec eva les salariés les adp
tout de suite le lien se ferait entre
limonest sur le service public des
transports et directives européennes la
question d'économie sociale des salaires
quant à jean luc mélenchon en tout cas
il est convaincu ou cette campagne
soumaré alico
y a pas un endroit où vous avez barca il
passe donc du sud en coupe klaxons loti
gay dans la rue qui a touché la marbre
vraiment une il ya quelque chose de
populaire autour d'eux
j'ai rien de ça paye des peines qu'on
peut se donner
et à l'assemblée nationale aussi marie
george buffet fait campagne encore et
toujours sur le registre social
80% des décisions que nous prenons à
l'assemblée nationale sont marquées par
des choix faits au niveau de l'europe
donc il faut changer d'europe pour
changer de politique aussi en france
parti de gauche + pc combien d'élus
combien de voix et au profit de qui la
dirigeante communiste élude la question
les luttes on va gagner tous les deux si
on fait une belle campagne ensemble si
on a un bon résultat et si on continue à
élargir l'assemblement après l'alliance
avec jean luc mélenchon semble avoir
redonné des couleurs à marie georges
buffet défendre les services publics